[Music]
in your live shows you're you're very
energetic and because the technology and
for a number of years now uh you can
play uh there's a there's a radio device
on the on the guitar that enables you to
just run anywhere and play your guitar
in the crowd when you run out into those
big stadium crowds i would think that
would get a little out of control
sometimes you've got these people going
crazy you're trying to play
actually keep up with the song
or we did we did a thing one night uh i
was playing i go out through the crowd
and i'm running through the crowd with
my guitar and this woman came over and
sort of grabbed my guitar and was you
know waving and everything i'm like fine
you know and i and i'm
and i'm keep moving through the crowd
and i noticed that she's just like
tagging along with me and she's
latched on to my guitar
and i'm like hi okay give me the guitar
and and the further i go she is just
keeping up with me and just right there
and i'm thinking this woman is crazy and
i'm trying to almost kick her off the
guitar you know literally and and i'm
pulling the guitar neck so
aggressively and i look down
she's got this top that i've snagged in
my guitar
and i've
actually been pulling her along for
about three hours
she's trying to get untangled
yeah and uh for a woman she's like i'm
not even that big a fan
she was actually security which is crazy
yeah but um that is hilarious yeah so i
untangled it all like a fish from the
net and her thing is her whole top is
just sagging down here and
i just think that was like yeah and and
then what about like uh the the
when you're trying to communicate like
with an audience that's that big you
know uh you're talking huge arena crowds
and you're trying to make a connection
is that difficult if you're trying to do
what i mean in a more intimate setting i
would think it would be easier and a lot
of the times i mean depending on the
place you consider people are you
screaming things out and you you'll hear
you know
much better things these days than i
used to hear
uh but this girl yelled out uh one night
we're in the serene this girl yelled out
well you signed my leg and i thought
well that's this will be a good moment
i'll bring her up on stage we'll sign
the leg and everything and i said sure
and i see her head disappear in amongst
all the people i'm like what's going on
next minute her head comes up and she
throws this thing at the stage
unhook this prosthetic leg
so i sign it and then i'm thinking
what's what's the proper prosthetic leg
returning etiquette yeah right
do you do you throw it back no do you
crowd surfer do you
make her hop up onto the stage no you
don't do it everything you just said
right there is wrong what would you do
how would you get that first i'd like be
like thank you and hang on to it
the crowd would get so mad it would turn
on me i don't know what you do that is
so i thought i had i thought i had seen
it all at this point i've never seen
anything like that yeah
you can't really throw it back not
really right i i sort of gingerly crowd
surfed it back and it made its way uh
now i understand that you uh not too
long ago you had to have vocals sir you
had serious vocal issues at the end of
uh 2011. 2011 yeah and you had to have
surgery for it i did yeah i had a nodule
on one chord and a polyp on the other
but i i got them
removed and it's been good ever since
was it one of those things where they
said okay uh
after the surgery or before you know you
can't speak for a while yeah well i
couldn't speak for quite a few weeks and
um because i would not be able to not
speak that was the bad part yeah
actually wasn't the hard part not
speaking it was it well it's it's in
communicating with nick and our kids was
with you know it's being silent every
day day in day out was
was challenging particularly you don't
want to have an argument with your wife
when you can't speak that's that's all i
can say because i'm writing on a board
and when you get really heated i'm like
breaking pens you know i'm like
it doesn't help to write really hard
when you're angry right you can't help
it you know there are only so many
exclamation points you can use to get
your point i think i was writing this is
unacceptable you know and i broke the
pen and
that's just sad yeah this is
unacceptable
no wonder i broke where do you see what
i've got
hold on
yeah it went down that well too yeah